the opening scene begins with an
animated scene of seabrook which was the
perfect town to live in and raise
children unfortunately 50 years ago a
factory worker accidentally overturned a
bottle of soda causing a chemical plant
explosion a large amount of toxic gas
was leaked and as a result nearly half
of the population turned into zombies
the local government quickly acted and a
barrier was constructed to keep the
zombies away from the normal people in
the next scene we see a zombie named zed
who lives with his father and younger
sister zoe they reside in a quarantined
area known as zombietown which separates
the humans from the living dead it is
revealed that scientists have recently
designed a device named the z band or
the zed band if you're in canada which
prevents the zombies from turning into
their real selves this allows zombie
children to enter human school where
they can get equal education like human
children meanwhile zed is excited to
attend his first day at human school he
tries his best to get in shape as he
wants to get selected for the football
team on the contrary his father is
skeptical as he believes that humans
should not be trusted he also advises
his son to stay away from humans
elsewhere we are introduced to a normal
high school girl named addison she is
admitted to the same school as zed and
is looking forward to joining the
cheerleading squad however she has a
rare deformity which causes her hair to
become white since the people of
seabrook are against anything abnormal
and there are no weebs here to think
it's cool addison has to hide her secret
under a wig she is also supported by her
parents who work as zombie patrolling
officers for seabrook high school the
next day is the first day of school zed
joins his friends and heads to the high
school and so does addison the zombies
are excited about the proposition of
finally being treated as equals but when
they arrive at the school they realize
that this isn't the case said to be for
the safety of human students the zombies
are segregated and taught inside a
separate basement moreover they are not
allowed to talk or even have any contact
with human students addison believes
that the zombies are just like humans
and that they should be allowed to live
freely however her popular friend bucky
opposes the idea and thinks that they
are inferior in the basement the school
principal lee greets the zombie students
but she herself appears to be disgusted
by them zedd asks the principal if they
can play in the football games to which
she replies that they're not permitted
to leave the basement during school time
despite this zed skips class and heads
upstairs to find the football field as
he is investigating the area several
students notice him and start freaking
out one of them rings the zombie alarm
causing mayhem in the building zed tries
to convince everyone that he's harmless
but the students don't listen to him
soon he notices a group of boys
approaching him and flees to the zombie
safe room to hide simultaneously addison
also enters the same room and notices
someone inside because the room appears
to be quite dark neither of them can see
the other's face addison begins
conversing with zed unaware of his true
identity just then the light comes back
on and when addison realizes that she
was talking to a zombie she punches him
hard in the face however she soon
realizes her mistake and apologizes a
few moments later bucky and his friends
arrive at the zombie safe room and take
addison away later zed tries out for the
football team but the coach turns him
down due to school rules meanwhile
addison and the other students are
auditioning for a spot on the
cheerleading team which is being led by
none other than bucky after a good
performance addison is chosen for the
team but her best friend bree is
rejected seeing bree sad addison talks
to bucky and eventually persuades him to
let brie in however before both of them
can join bucky mentions that they will
have to go through a tradition which
involves throwing eggs at zombie homes
the duo is puzzled but for the sake of
the cheerleading team they agree in the
next scene bucky drops addison and brie
off in the zombie town and instructs
them to egg any one of the zombies
houses addison is astounded by the
surroundings since it is her first time
in the other half of the barrier just
then a zombie woman approaches the group
frightening the life out of them as a
result bucky flees in terror while
addison and brie seek refuge behind some
furniture meanwhile zed comes out from
his house and notices the two of them
after seeing the eggs in their hands zed
assumes that the girls have just come to
egg the house hence he walks inside
disappointed seeing this sadison becomes
sad as she believes that the zombies
deserve better treatment but she also
wants to be a cheerleader so she's
probably gonna throw that egg the
following day at school addison
approaches bucky and tells him not to
harass the zombies but he ignores her he
then lightly touches her hair signaling
that he will expose her flaw if she
continues to rebel meanwhile zed and his
friends eliza and bonzo enter the
basement class and start conversing zed
tells them about the incident from the
previous day and concludes that all
cheerleaders are bad just then addison
arrives in the basement and apologizes
to zed for the previous evening she then
invites him to the pep rally shocking
everyone eliza informs her that zombies
do not attend pep rallies but zed who
seems to have a crush on addison says
that he will come later addison is
pleased to see zed and his friends in
the audience at the pep rally on the
contrary the other human students
including bucky are enraged soon the
rally begins and everyone begins to
enjoy the show taking advantage of the
situation bucky brings out some fire
candles on purpose which freaks bonzo
out zed attempts to calm bonzo but he
pushes him away and runs towards the
stage zed falls down and unfortunately
his z band is damaged he starts turning
into a full-blown zombie but despite
this he follows bonzo in order to stop
him on the way he accidentally hits some
football players causing them to fall
far away the football coach sees this
and appears to be impressed zed then
runs towards the stage and saves addison
from falling to the ground in the
process he somehow manages to reactivate
his zombie band in the next scene the
coach takes zed to the principal and
offers him a spot on the football team
zed agrees but only on the condition
that the other zombie students be
allowed to eat in the school cafeteria
just like humans the principal
reluctantly agrees and bucky who
overhears their conversation is furious
because his plan has failed later the
zombie students arrive at the cafeteria
but the human students as usual despise
them however they don't complain as they
are enjoying their time in the cafeteria
meanwhile addison keeps staring at zed
and tells brie that she likes him a few
moments later zed waves at addison
surprising every human student addison
then walks over to the zombie table and
starts talking to them the other zombies
also seem to like her but just then
bucky's followers arrive and take her
away they warn her that bucky will be
upset if she talks to the zombies after
this edison walks away and zed follows
her to the zombie safe room where the
duo enjoy one another's company a while
later addison takes their friendship to
the next level oh mama by revealing that
she has white hair oh the next day zed
plays his first football game but fails
to perform well and disappoints everyone
during half time the coach inquires
about his strength during the pep rally
on remembering zed realizes that his
zombie band can supply him with the zom
boost he immediately heads to eliza who
is a computer expert and requests that
she hack into his zombie band eliza
initially refuses claiming that it is
cheating but when zed mentions that they
will get more facilities if he wins the
game she agrees after hacking the z band
zed enters the pitch again and this time
he scores numerous goals the zomboost
does wonders for him and ultimately his
team is victorious everyone in the
audience cheers for zed but bucky
appears to be envious the following day
the human student's attitude towards the
zombie students changes and they start
becoming friends their school wins
football matches one after another and
zed eventually becomes the most popular
student in high school bucky being
jealous approaches addison and asks her
to choose between being a
pro-cheerleader and being pro-zombie
addison has always wanted to be a
cheerleader so she reluctantly accepts
the cheerleading position with this she
is not permitted to support zedd during
the games despite her request and
despite the fact that that's literally
her job one evening addison receives a
message from zed asking her to meet him
at the barrier in the next scene addison
meets zedd who takes her to the
zombietown party addison is excited to
be at the party so the two of them start
having fun after a while addison notices
zoe who is cheerleading by herself she
compliments her cheerleading and the two
quickly become friends a while later
addison also meets eliza and finds her
to be intelligent and attractive as the
duo chat eliza gradually comes to think
of addison as a cool human soon zed
takes addison to the zombie light garden
and as they get closer zed notices her
white hair and complements its beauty
the two of them are about to kiss each
other when the zombie patrol arrives and
shuts down the party zed flees and the
officer takes addison home later
addison's parents learn that she's
seeing a guy and inquire about him when
addison refuses to reveal anything her
parents blackmail her by forbidding her
from participating in cheerleading the
next day at school zed and eliza discuss
changing some functions of the zombie
band unfortunately bucky's followers
overhear their conversation and realize
that he has been cheating with the z
band soon they notify bucky about the
secret and plan to sabotage zedd after a
while they go to eliza and secretly
steal her hacking computer on the other
hand zed meets addison who tells him
that her parents want to see him as they
don't know that he's a zombie later at
home zedd uses the help of his z band
and tries to change his appearance
elsewhere addison is about to inform her
parents of the truth but just then zed
appears disguised as a normal human
being he impresses her parents and asks
addison out on a date later as the newly
formed couple is in a restaurant addison
expresses her dissatisfaction that
they're changing themselves rather than
changing society's thoughts in the next
scene we are taken to the home game
where the entire crowd is cheering for
zed and his team surprisingly addison is
also supporting him despite being
ordered by bucky to not do so meanwhile
bucky's followers are tampering with
eliza's computer in an attempt to
destroy zed's z-band soon the plan works
and zed is unable to use the zomboost
however using his determination and
perseverance he manages to play
beautifully and score the winning goal
for his team who needs steroids anyway
just as zed is celebrating with his
teammates bucky's followers disintegrate
the z band and make it go offline as a
result zed along with eliza and bonzo
transform into zombies and start
attacking humans zed pursues bucky but
the zombie patrol arrives and takes
control of him in no time all humans
start yelling at the zombies so addison
stands up to them and criticizes human
selfishness she also reveals that zed
has put his life in danger in order to
lead their team to several victories she
then removes her wig revealing her
natural hair to everyone but the
audience just booze her following this
the zombies are returned to zombie town
while eliza is disappointed in humans
claiming that they will never change the
next day bucky confronts every single
cheerleader who is wearing zombie attire
on the other hand the zombies have now
returned to the basement class after
learning that eliza is planning to
sabotage the cheerleader championship
competition zed and bonzo rush to stop
her when they arrive zed tries to
persuade eliza to stop but addison
arrives and supports eliza however zed
convinces them that this is not the
zombie way to retaliate amidst their
heated discussion they soon realize that
their school's performance isn't going
well and as a result the audience starts
booing them just then zoe walks onto the
stage and begins performing on her own
seeing this zed gathers the zombies and
cheerleaders and performs on stage
meanwhile bucky is impressed by little
zoey's courage so he changes his mind
and joins the zombies on stage whoopee
together they perform an impressive
dance routine which sends the audience
into a state of pure bliss after the
performance zed and addison hug each
other the movie then cuts to a few days
later where it is revealed that seabrook
high school didn't win the competition
however what they did win was the
perception of humans who have now
started liking the zombies the movie
ends as the zombies and humans dance
together and celebrate a festival in
zombie town subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching